[Music]
hey y'all we need to talk about far cry
6 because this game has one of my
favorite actors in it my name is
giancarlo esposito
and i'm preparing to bring you my most
monstrous villain yet anton castillo in
far cry 6. so my favorite bad guy is
making the jump into games that's great
news for far cry 6. and the fans of the
series already know why far cry is known
for its larger-than-life villains this
is a legacy i intend to honor here's a
little bit more about the character
anton castillo is the ruthless dictator
of yara a beautiful caribbean island
nation because anton is you know
ruthless he is facing off against a
group of rebels who call themselves
libertad he's also facing off against
you the player and he's not afraid to
use his insane arsenal to keep power
anton possesses an exquisite firearm
forged from solid gold you wield a
child's backpack
anton has built a vast arsenal for his
loyal army you disrespect them you steal
their tanks as you scurry from building
to building you also can't help but feel
for san diego if anton has his way diego
will rule yara one day and diego has to
navigate a loving and twisted
relationship with his father say what
you will about your parents but they
probably never put a live grenade into
your hand just to teach you a lesson our
country
is like this grenade except it has two
basic parts
our
people
and you
and you must clutch them nice
and died or
we all
go
boom
so while he's messing [ __ ] up anton is
also making a drug that helps fight
cancer so fighting this guy kind of puts
you right in the middle of a moral
dilemma you are playing the character
danny who is actually a voice character
and not a silent protagonist anymore i
am nothing like you i watch castillo
order a whole both of our people shocked
to death
and i want to know who's going to help
me take him down
[Music]
okay as you travel through yara you
encounter fascinating characters like
clara garcia a journalist who became the
leader of libertad and juan cortez a
former kgb spy master operating in yara
and at this point you gotta ask yourself
can you really trust a former kgb agent
with a pet crocodile
[Music]
one of my favorite parts of the game is
the fangs for hire system you can
recruit different animals to help you
with different missions including this
totally adorable dog named chorizo
and can we talk about the fighting in
this game we're at army of one against
an army of thousands it's epic and there
are so many new and exciting weapons you
could use to help you fight along the
way
for example that furiosa backpack
oh
that is super new to the franchise i am
so excited to play you have all the
tools you need to fight alongside the
resistance and overthrow anton castillo
the fight is literally in your hands the
only question is do you have what it
takes
check out far cry 6 on october 7th on
xbox series s xbox series x and other
platforms
play it on the all-new xbox